jacques gobert alors à la 150e début
février il y avait déjà plus de cent
mille spectateurs qui étaient venus voir
la pièce ce qui est n 1 et comme dirait
mon ami laurent ruquier la presse est
unanime elle combats de monstres le
figmag bruel la surprise est totale et
très heureuse
valeurs actuelles bruel est excellent le
parisien pari gagné bruel joue se farde
se travestit l'on n'y croit le figaro
françois bruel est bluffant s'appelle
mangé son pain blanc très agréable pour
une rentrée au théâtre ça fait très
longtemps que j'en ai pas vu passer
devant c'est flatteur c'est très
encourageant pour continuer à prendre
des risques et la centrale du parti
qu'une avoir un bon alors on a lu cela
et maintenant on va voir ça
parce qu'à aussi le disque alors ça
c'est encore plus incroyable succès
total avec l'album entre deux reprises
de succès des années 30 et qui sort
d'ailleurs en coffret avec 3 3 cd sur
les deux coffrets du cd entre deux plus
large était un voisin qualifiait
original on a mis les versions
originales dedans pour revoir toutes les
gens vous un petit peu ce qu'on a laissé
oui
voilà entre 2 le nouveau faux frais avec
les procédés et la chanson qu'on entend
beaucoup en ce moment c'est avec charles
aznavour
c'est ça les limites
la chaîne laisser mon coeur
c'est là que je viens retrouver
toujours mon voeu
quand je revois ma petite et où les
marges
malgré les gens nous
m
après quoi elle met les mentors de
charabot est-ce que vous pouvez demander
plus à la ville cette année
quel cadeau claouey quel cadeau ils
m'ont fait ce désert cesse ses chansons
et quelques uns de hommes ont fait tous
ces artistes qui sont venus sur l'album
c'est c'est vraiment un très beau moment
ouais ouais c'est très beau je suis très
très heureux et très chanceux